[Music]
what's up everybody this your boy troy
king aka tking mode before we get into
today's topic i wanted to start off with
some honorable mentions
so today let's start off with some
honorable mention quarterbacks justin
fields and trevor lawrence last year
absolutely atrocious
highly drafted quarterbacks completely
disappointed for fantasy purposes this
year they got new head coaches i believe
for the most part the offense is going
to be better mainly for trevor
lawrence's sake but i believe they're
both talented both big arms both are
more mobile quarterbacks so i believe
they present some upside later in drafts
if you want to wait on quarterback and
you don't want to spend up especially if
in new york standard one quarterback
league
in terms of honorable mention tight ends
we got pat friendmouth and gerald
everett pat friamuth
last year he scored seven touchdowns had
60 receptions with ben roethlisberger or
the shell of ben roethlisberger and in
terms of jailed everett he's now
attached to justin herber now let me
tell you about jared cook last year so
jared cook was the tight end on the
chargers last year he saw 83 targets if
gerald everett who is younger more
athletic than jared cook could see
anywhere in that range
gerald everett is going to shine for
fantasy purposes
concerns honorable mention wide receiver
jalen tolbert he has a pathway to the
second wide receiver on that team in
terms of the cowboys that positions wide
open with injuries so jalen tolbert he
can take that advantage of that and in
terms of running backs honorable mention
brian robinson with the washington
commanders
there's a lot of antonio gibson you know
rumors in terms of we don't know what's
going to happen with him i think he
might lose some opportunities and damian
pierce the houston running back
like that
running back room is wide open so i'm
very excited to see what he can do in
that offense he could possibly be that
starting running back
all right guys let's put up that poll
real quick let's give the people what
they wanted you chose
we delivered now let's go to the poll
results real quick
now
you guys wanted sleepers right so we had
three options sleepers to win your
league best player in every round
fantasy stacks to target
sleepers who win your league won by a
large margin
56.3 percent so i'm just going to get
into what you guys came for so i'm going
to go from 10 to one and these are
sleepers that you're going to see in
from the 10th round 11th round 12th
round these are the rounds that gonna
help you win your league anybody can
make a good pick in the first and third
round i'm gonna help you find guys are
going to be those difference makers now
i'm going to start off with my number 10
guy
my number 10 guy is
hunter
henry
now before you throw tomatoes at me i
know that the patriots offense isn't
sexy right it was it was pretty gross
especially passing wise last year they
were running team you know what damian
harris monjay stevenson all that and
hunter henry in terms of tight end
finishes
he didn't finish that great last year he
was only 15th in points per game amongst
tight ends so why am i so excited about
him well the reason i'm so excited is
because he was first he was one first
overall in terms of receiving touchdowns
amongst all tight ends he was second and
total touchdowns but he scored the most
he had nine touchdowns last year y'all
now i don't think most people realize
that he had nine touchdowns so that's
one of the reasons i'm so excited about
him and he was seventh overall amongst
tight ends in terms of red zone targets
but on his own team he led all the tight
ends ny receivers in terms of red zone
opportunities
so when you look at tight ends
look thailand's are very hard to predict
in fantasy for the most part
and it's not that hard to finish as a
tight end one basically you're gonna get
a lot of targets or score touchdowns for
tight ends not a lot of them are getting
a bunch of targets so we're gonna look
for the guys that score touchdowns even
though it's not a sticky stat you can't
always predict touchdowns every year
but there's no reason this year why
hunter henry isn't going to be a red
zone target for mack jones i know matt
patricia is the offensive coordinator so
trust me i am definitely worried about
that but if you look at their wide
receiver core it's not that impressive i
don't see any reason why hunter henry
isn't going to be a go-to target again
this year in the red zone so for me i'm
very excited about him and he he's late
in drafts right you don't have to
necessarily spend up on the travis
kelsey george kittle you know dan wall
if you don't want to if you want to
focus on other positions then you can
wait on tight end and you can get a guy
like hunter henry
all right now i'm gonna transition to my
number nine guy
it's another girls offense hope you know
just bear with me so my number nine guy
is cole commit
another tight end
so again i know this is a gross offense
y'all so just bear with me
cole comment
last year got 93 targets that's 93. the
only problem was
he scored zero touchdowns like you can't
even make that up right 93 targets and
scoring zero touchdowns you want to know
why he scored zero touchdowns well
mainly because of you know justin fields
and andy dalton at the time weren't very
accurate but also for some reason jimmy
graham kept stealing all the touchdowns
for whatever reason i don't know but
jimmy graham no longer there cocomet is
the starting tight end they got a new
you know head coach so i'm very
optimistic about call comment this year
another reason why i'm optimistic is
because look at their wide receivers
it's darnell mooney and cole command and
you have brian pringle
equinamia saint brown are we really
expecting these guys to command a high
target share
i don't think so and also cole commit
last year he was second on the team in
targets he was eighth in targets amongst
tight ends and he was sixth in deep
targets among tight ends we should see
something similar this year because
justin fields only has so many options
to pass it to so when i'm looking for a
tight end late i'm looking for a guy can
he be
at least second option on the team
colcomet is screaming that he could be
the second option in targets on the team
that's why i'm especially excited about
him
now before i get into
my eighth guy let's go through the chat
real quick guys and i look i appreciate
you guys tuning in i want to make sure i
answer your questions so make sure you
drop your questions in the chat i'm
gonna be looking throughout them all
right
so
let's see christian and this is from
kirth e christian watson and dobs both
going and viable options by mid way to
the end of the season okay so i want to
talk about christian watson and dobbs
real quick so i like both of them
christian watson
he's been missing time obviously during
the preseason he's been dealing with
some injuries but
i believe you know he just drafted in
the second round
by the packers i think he's very raw
talent but he's big athletic
i think with aaron rodgers though he
doesn't trust rookies he's already been
on record saying you know some of the
rookies have been messing up their
routes and haven't really you know been
making some mistakes during the off
season so i don't know if dobbs or
christian watson at least early in the
season are going to make a significant
impact i believe christian watson is
more talented but dom's has really been
making some noise in preseason so i like
where they're going i don't mind you
guys taking a shot on them so yeah in
terms of
both of them if you want to take a shot
late go for it but i think the dividends
aren't gonna pay until later in the
season but i really like that question
now i'm gonna get to the rest of your
guys questions in a little bit
but let me go to my number eight guy
my number eight guy
is going to be
davis
mills
now at this point you guys must be
wondering why am i picking these scrubs
but
you gotta hear me out here davis mills
houston texans quarterback
he is not as bad as most people think
right you hear the name you think of the
team you think oh my gosh this guy's
garbage but that's not the case
shout out to my guy laquan jones he's a
researcher with the nfl he helped
provide me with this stat
davis mills led all rookies and
completion percentage and passing yards
per game as a starter
he only trailed mac jones in passing
touchdowns pass to touchdown ratio and
passer rating in the last 10 games he
had 14 touchdowns and only five
interceptions
and he had two games with 300 plus
passing yards and three touchdowns no
interceptions and if we really look at
the rookie class and i mentioned justin
fields trevor lawrence zach wilson they
were atrocious they were not good and
davis mills i think bill hein mack jones
he was the second best rookie and the
coaching staff they believed in him they
brought him back they didn't they could
have drafted the guy they didn't want to
draft a guy they have a lot of
confidence at dates mills i think their
weapons are pretty good you still have
brandon cooks i think nico collins is
underrated so and then john metchi i
know he's hurt but
i think they they might have a sneaky
squad i don't think they're going to be
a good team but for fantasy purpose wise
if you're looking for a streamer type of
quarterback i think davis mills is
somebody you can look at again if you're
in your standard one quarterback lead
where you start two running backs
to the three wide receivers you can load
up on those guys and not have to take a
quarterback early and you can wait on
davis mills or if you aren't into the
streaming game davis mills is the type
of guy that i really like in terms of
look one quarterback leads i don't like
paying off for quarterback i like
waiting
but now
this leads me to my seventh guy
it's also a quarterback and this guy has
a little more upside than davis mills
and this is going to be tua tiger viola
and
here i'm i'm going to give you a spoiler
y'all i am a dolphins fan i am a
dolphins fan but that's not the reason
why i put tua at seven i put two at
seven because
it's hard to ignore
the addition of tyreek hill
mike mcdaniels as the new head coach
it's going to be a very exciting offense
and one of the things that the dolphins
have lacked
for a long time is one the protection
the o-line has also upgraded the o-line
has been horrible for years the dolphins
have not had a run game and god knows
how long right since jay ajayi lamar
miller days they've been struggling to
run the ball for quite some time as well
as the offensive line hasn't been able
to protect them so there's been a lot of
two aha
and also the play calling has been very
vanilla and in the past couple years the
defenses have been helping you know to
win games so the offense no one's really
wanted to touch they have had
fantasy viable options but overall the
dolphins have been mediocre but now you
got tyree kill you got jayla waddle even
cedric wilson is a sneaky guy that you
can get laid in your drafts but tua
i think people want to hate on him
i don't think it's justified so we look
at the numbers last year per player
profiler two was actually first in deep
ball completion percentage he was third
in accuracy rating and he was first in
red zone completion percentage so people
want to talk about how tua can throw
where he sucks or whatever and that's
just not true he just needs the
opportunity to not be rushed all the
time he needs that protection and he
needs creative play calling so i believe
this year with mike mcdaniels and all
the weapons he's somebody again you can
wait on in drafts load up on the running
backs and wide receivers the ones that
actually you need to fill out your team
and then like you don't have to
necessarily get a patch from holmes
lamar lamar jackson
if you're in a 1qb league wait for guys
that have that you know upside and then
focus on the other positions
now before i get to my number six guy
i'm gonna go back to the chat i
appreciate you guys dropping
questions in here
okay
from aidan malloy aydah malloy wants to
know my thoughts on kj handler
i like kj hamler a lot actually
especially with the tim patrick injury
we need somebody to step up in there so
kj hamlin last year he was injured
unfortunately he presents huge upside
with russell wilson
so and kj hamler is basically free he's
going so late he could might as well he
could possibly be on the waiver wire
right he's gonna even go back of your
drafts or wave a wire guy at this point
he might slowly climb up towards the
beginning of the season
but i think kj hamler is a guy with
sneaky upside especially if you play
best ball
kj hamler is a guy that i don't know if
he's going to be a target hog but if
you're looking for somebody at a big
play upside if you want to put him in
your flex spot i think kj hamler is the
type of guy that i like in terms of that
i'm gonna read one more question
from crike's next sleeper gotta be trey
lance
so trey lance to me
i'll tell you why trey lance is
he's two he's the new hotness right i
didn't want to talk about trey lambs
because there's gonna be a lot of people
talking about trade lands but i'll
address it right trey lance to me
is gonna be similar to jalen hurts last
year
trey lance is gonna win you some fantasy
football titles and it might not always
be pretty right he he's a raw talent but
what we look for
in our quarterbacks we look for guys
with big arms we can have big plays we
look at their you know weapons and a guy
who runs the ball trey lands as long as
he stays healthy
he's going to win you championship
leagues but that's somebody that you're
going to probably have to pay up for a
little bit right he's going to be going
in the middle rounds he's going to be
going i think
top 8 quarterbacks
at this point especially as the season
starts so yeah trey lance he's
definitely going to win people some
leagues but
i want to give you guys some later round
guys because people are going to be
battling for trey lance but i really do
like that question
all right guys so i'm going to
transition to my number six guy
but number six guy and i actually have
three wide receivers that i'm gonna be
talking about they're all rookies but
i'm gonna start off with my first one
george
pickens
now you might have heard a lot about
george pickens during this offseason
that hype has been absolutely out of
control in the preseason game he looked
really good so george pickens for those
who don't know
he's a rookie wide receiver he's with
the steelers 6'3 200 pounds runs a 447
guy's an athletic freak
last year in college he tours acl so
that's why he might have not has much
buzz about him that's why he fell a
little bit in the draft but his freshman
and sophomore year he led his teams in
receptions as well as in he led his
teams and receptions his freshman year
and sophomore year but even deante
johnson
this could just be a teammate thing but
he was talking about how he's a freak
and he's a special talent and the
coaching staff seems to love him i think
if you are targeting chase claypool i'd
be worried there's a good chance that
george pickens from what i've heard he
could maybe take that wide receiver two
job
it's still early speculation but if you
look at some of the you know
beat writers the the news
george pickens is making a lot of noise
i believe it's real and his adp is going
to be climbing so you want to make sure
that you get you some shares of george
pickens i'm really really interested in
him
all right and let me go to my number
five guy real quick another rookie wide
receiver
it's jahan datsun the jahan dante was my
guy going into the draft right he's was
drafted 16th overall by the washington
commanders
now and
when he was drafted at 16 i think a lot
of people were shot people like who is
this guy jahan dodson in college had
strong hands excellent route runner i
believe he's a very good compliment to
terry mclaren
and i know that carson wentz is the
quarterback and i know that the
commanders are not going to be a good
team but you know one thing about bad
teams that i love i love that they have
to throw the ball and i love garbage
time and you know why because garbage
time and bad teams they still score
fantasy points and not all the targets
can't go to terry mclaurin and listen
you don't spend the 16th overall pick on
the wide receiver if you don't expect to
use him early and often jahan dodson
he's going like the 12th 13th round
you're looking at that range you're
looking for wide receivers with upside
and jahan dodson even with carson wentz
he's going to get the targets right
maybe would they all be quality targets
maybe not but i believe they're going to
be losing a lot of games they're going
to have to throw a lot of games and
johan dots is going to get lesser
coverage than terry mclaurin so that's
one of the reasons i'm really excited
about johan dotson and again he's an
excellent round runner strong hands he's
going to catch his targets i believe
he's going to score touchdowns he's
going to get a lot of coverage than tara
mclaurin so i'm really liking him as a
sneaky upside player
now before i go to my number four guy
let me go back to the chat i appreciate
you guys dropping questions
let me see oh
i'm gonna so toweler at tower thoughts
on pollard versus seek polit has given
consistently been better running back
but hasn't been given the chances like
zeke with the reps and red zone touches
now
i actually this is a great question to
alex i appreciate you talking about him
so
one thing we have to remember is that
last year zeke was playing through an
injury
i think pollard because he's not he's
used in a specific way
he has a lot of juice right so last year
he looked like he had a lot more juice
than zeke
and part of the reason why is because
it's just the way he's used right he's
not zeke is the grinder right they're
two different running backs zeke is the
grinder he's the one that getting the
dirty yards
tony pollard he's not that workhorse
running back so i don't we're never
gonna see him just take on that full
workload as well as jerry you already
mentioned jerry mentioned they're paying
zeke a lot of money so as long as zeke's
on the team he is going to be getting
the ball regardless he's a bigger back
when he's healthy he's he's been one of
the best running backs in the league and
he's been an rb one every single year so
even last year he was an rb1 i know it's
he doesn't always do it in the prettiest
way and i think people have zeke fatigue
but he's a very good running back still
right and then just i
if you want to draft poller i think that
he's still somebody that's very viable
to draft but i don't see him ever
getting that rb1 job i think he's always
going to be a compliment there were
talks in camp
during the off season that paula could
be played in the slot so to me
he's similar to a guy i'm gonna be
talking about a little bit but
i i do like pollard but zeke told me
he's still the rb1 he's still the guy
that you want in draft
now i'm gonna go to my number four guy
my number four guy
is garrett wilson
garrett wilson with the new york jets
now garrett wilson was drafted 10th
overall
and we just saw the news that zach
wilson's hurt you know joe flacco is
going to be the qb for a while zach
wilson's going to come back eventually
but gary wilson was actually my wide
receiver one
going into the draft i believe he's a
very special talent and the only reason
why i think people aren't higher on
garrett wilson is because
people think the jets suck which they
kind of do let's be honest they're not
very good team and there's elijah moore
there but let's look at their adps
elijah moore's adp or average draft
position is around like the 80 mark
garrett wilson is going at like um the
120
mark overall that's a huge range
for somebody garrett wilson
he's believed to be a better talent
than elijah moore was going to the draft
last year now elijah moore had a very
good run last year i think he's a great
wide receiver and maybe he's the guy
that you want but with that adp
difference
i'm willing to maybe not take an elijah
moore and i think garrett wilson he's
like he's an excellent he's one of the
best wide receivers he was to me the
best wide receiver in this draft class
i'm extremely excited about him and i
think that
people are going to be sleeping on him i
also think the jets aren't going to be a
very good team so you're going to have
to throw the ball a lot elijah moore is
not going to get all the targets and
garrett wilson is a
hell of a wide receiver so i think gary
wilson somebody you should easily be
targeting your drafts especially with
that draft capital like i said about
johan dotson
you don't spend the 10th overall pick on
a wide receiver and don't expect to
feature him heavily so i really like
garrett wilson and we've seen rookie
wide receivers just go off the past few
years chase waldo justin jefferson
i'm not saying gary wilson is going to
be them but i'm very excited about what
he can do in this offense
all right
now let me go into my top three guys
y'all the top three guys my number three
guy is naive hines
now
nayeem heinz
i know jonathan taylor was on the team
yeah so i don't need anybody telling me
about jonathan taylor he's still the man
but naeem hines since he's been in the
league pretty much he's been one of the
best pass catching running backs in the
game at least top three top five where
he wanted to put him so last year he had
40 receptions 310 yards
56 rushing attempts 276 yards
those aren't you know fantastic numbers
but he was 12 in targets last year among
the running backs one thing that he's
going to consistently get is targets and
who is his new quarterback his new
quarterback is matt ryan and one thing
we know about rat matt ryan
he is not a mobile guy carson wentz at
least was a little bit mobile and maybe
that's one of the reasons he didn't get
even as more targets than that but back
with like with phillip rivers
phillip rivers targeted the heck out of
naeem hines so i believe this year on
third downs we know our name heinz is
gonna have that unlock there's gonna be
times where matt ryan he's not gonna run
for the first down he is going to dump
that off we know he likes to check down
and guess who's going to check it down
too diamond hides and jonathan taylor
like he's going to get his i don't need
you i don't need to tell you guys how
good he's going to be but
knock on wood in case he gets injured or
even if he doesn't get injured named
heinz has standalone value regardless
even with jonathan taylor but he could
he's not he's a guy with standalone
value plus if jonathan taylor does get
injured named behind adp and stock is
just going to go through the absolute
roof so i'm in love with name highs that
is adp especially even a ppr league
whether you're in a half or full ppr i
absolutely love naim heinz and let me
look at one more question in the chat
for right now then i'll go to my last
two guys
okay jiffy
at jiffy what's your take on the splits
between aaron jones and aj dylan this
season
now
for where aaron jones and aj dylan
aaron rodgers just came out recently and
said that he wouldn't be shocked if aj
dillon and aaron jones got like 50
target sheets or 50 catches each or
something like that
to me aaron jones is the guy that you
want in terms of ppr
he's the past catcher right it's like
we've seen him last year he was targeted
a lot by aaron rodgers and without any
devante adams they're gonna have to use
both of them consistently but aj dylan
this man is 250 pounds
you he not really i don't know why
you're really necessarily going to be
throwing it to him you want to use him
on first and second down as well as
touchdowns that's why you want to use
him right so
i think that maybe aj dylan is the guy
that scores more touchdowns because it
just makes logical sense to give your
biggest back the goal line work because
last year we saw aaron rodgers throw the
devonta items on the goal line like a
crazy amount of times but to me in terms
of ppr wise i like aaron jones better i
think he's a better receiver and i think
he's still the rb1 or if you want to say
1a1b but i prefer aaron jones but both
of them are going to get theirs for sure
all right now i'm going to go to my last
two guys my second guy
is going to be he's a running back
on a not good team it's khalil
herber
now you guys might have remembered last
year when david montgomery got hurt
khalil herbert from weeks five to eight
last year he averaged 14 ppr points
and also he put up over 100 yards in two
of those games he went off he was the
waiver wire darling at those times he
was very explosive he looked really good
right he looked like he had juice
somewhere like to me i i think of it in
a way of like tony parlor got
they're different backs but you know the
backup guy getting their shot khalil
herbert to me
is that guy that is going to take him
some work from monty and from david
montgomery we even heard during this
offseason during the preseason training
camp how
damn montgomery was practicing with the
special teams
i'll i'll tell you guys right now you
don't want your starting running back to
ever be associated with special teams
that's a red flag i don't care if it's
co-speak or whatever
but
it shouldn't happen right you're not
hearing about any other starting running
back and the word special teams in the
same sentence so that makes me a little
bit worried about david montgomery in
terms of his workload and splits or
maybe
so i think that khalil herbert i think
he has some standalone value as well but
if monty gets hurt again khalil herbert
is a guy that could possibly be a league
winner i mean get i don't wish for
injuries but you always got to be
prepared for them right nfl is a brutal
game injuries happen all the time
so cleo herbert
again he's also getting you know reps
with the ones that's somebody that could
be an absolute
you know
league winner
if you are able to draft him i'm i've
have him on so many of my teams just in
case but yeah clil herbert you see him
right down there he could possibly be a
league winner for you
now
i gotta talk about my number one guy i
hope you guys have a pen and paper i
hope you guys have a pen and paper
because this is my number one guy
my number one guy
tampa bay running back
rashad
white
now rashad white
for those who don't know he was drafted
in the third round by the bucks
he's an excellent pass catcher y'all his
last year of college he saw 50 targets
put up 456 yards saw about a 16 target
share but he's not just a good pass
catching running back he can put in the
work on the ones and twos as well
and i know that leonard fournette is
there but leonard fernandez dealt with
injuries in his past and one thing that
tom brady likes he's not a mobile guy
we've been looking for somebody in that
offense to fulfill that quote-unquote
james white role giovanni menard wasn't
really yet ronald jones absolutely was
not it keyshawn vaughn absolutely not
leonard fournette he saw an outrageous
amount of targets last year so last year
atlanta for nat saw 69 receptions had
454
receiving yards that was third and
fourth amongst running backs expect
respectively that's not happening again
next year y'all this year rashad white
is going to be in on third downs i think
that if lenny gets hurt rashad white's
an absolutely winner but he has
standalone value he's going to be a
third down guy we know that brady loves
to check down to his running backs he's
a very special talent so rashad white
i'm telling you please draft him if you
have the ability to draft him he's an
excellent talent he's going to be
working the ones and twos as well and
again he to me he's a better pass
catching back than leonard fournette so
guys make sure you drive for sean white
he is a guy that can absolutely win you
your league
but i just want to say y'all that's
about it for me
look we have time's up i just want to
say thank you to everybody for joining
the stream for those who don't know my
name is troy king aka t king mode you
can find me at t king mo
pretty much on all social media
platforms but my home base is twitter i
really appreciate you guys in the chat
tuning in with your questions again
until next time thank you so much y'all
have yourselves a good one
[Music]